[Música]
un día que comienza con euforia absoluta
132 años después de la toma de argel por
los soldados franceses argelia recuperó
su soberanía hombres mujeres y niños
desfilan con trajes de fiesta con
banderas del fmln el frente de
liberación nacional el 5 de julio de
1962 se puso fin al dominio francés pero
también a más de siete años de guerra
cuatro días antes los votantes argelinos
votaron si a la autodeterminación al
abrir las urnas los musulmanes acudieron
en masa a los puestos de votación en
toda argelia se registró una alta
participación superior al 85 por ciento
la mayoría de los europeos presentes
participaron en la votación
muchos colonos europeos ya han
abandonado el país
desde los acuerdos debían firmados en
marzo que debían poner fin a las
hostilidades
argelia comienza a vivir un periodo de
violencia extrema
la organización del ejército secreto se
niega a abandonar el país y multiplica
los ataques contra la población
musulmana en orán el día de la
independencia comenzó con un tiroteo en
el barrio europeo
en el corazón de la ciudad mientras la
emoción estaba en pleno apogeo se
produjo un tiroteo casi un centenar de
personas murieron y 150 resultaron
heridas en ambas comunidades en realidad
varios cientos de personas murieron o
desaparecieron
linchamientos secuestros los
manifestantes ajustan cuentas con los
europeos sin la intervención del
ejército francés ni el ejército de
liberación nacional
[Música]
el drama había sumergido a la ciudad en
la angustia
otro factor de tensión en argelia la
división del ejecutivo los líderes de
los distintos clanes políticos se
enfrentan por el futuro del país todavía
no se ha llegado a un acuerdo entre las
tres partes en vela budiaf y belkacem
cream even queda el gobierno provisional
deben queda tiene los días contados a
partir de ahora
ahmed ben bela cuenta con el apoyo del
coronel bumedien jefe el ejército
fronterizo juntos entraron en argel en
septiembre y expulsaron a sus rivales su
victoria significó el ascenso del poder
militar